qui aurait pu imaginer que 2020 soit à
ce point inimaginable
pourtant les voyants et autres médiums
avait été interrogé et selon certains
d'entre eux 2020 allait permettre à
l'humanité de s'en sortir 2020 serait
une année lumineuse peau tout faux et en
regardant dans les archives de la
télévision
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
voyants voix troubles exemple en 1968
quelles sont vos prévisions pour l'année
1968 pour la mine va venir 168 je vois
un début d'année vraiment calme voyez
dans les affairés 1968 une année calme
en france on repassera des erreurs de
prédiction qui n'empêche pas les
journalistes d'aller interroger tous les
ans les voyants astrologues et autres
médiums exemple le 31 décembre 1973
nous sommes quelques mois avant la mort
du président pompidou
est ce que cette voyante l'avait vu
venir le président de la république
demandera par référendum ou peuple de
france en même temps que le
renouvellement anticipé de son mandat un
régime purement présidentielle sans
référendum sera un succès pour monsieur
pompidou pas de référendum 15 georges
pompidou meurent pendant son mandat le 2
avril 1974
dix ans plus tard les journalistes ont
toujours cette manie d'interroger les
voyant le nouveau t il les confronte ces
bons seraient pas l'apothéose mais
serait temps de mieux combattre les
craintes
moi je suis pas d'accord je maintiens
que la neige est très dur dans le monde
et en france particulièrement en ce
moment
il est un peu enrhumé d'enquêté il voit
tout en noir
dernier exemple celui de ce match qui
avait tout faux pour l'année 1988 1988
est une année essentielle puisque pour
la politique tout au moins et car il va
y avoir une élection présidentielle
alors que prévoyions mitterrand ont
dernièrement ne se représente pas
raymond barre et aider mais pour des
raisons de santé ne sera plus là un an
ou deux après simone veil va lui
succéder
elle ramène le mandat cinq saisons
simone veil présidente là encore il faut
sans être voyant ni astrologues
espérons tout de même que 2021 soit
meilleur que 2020 mais comment faire
pire
débouté au radiesthésie en pratique je
ne vois rien
[Musique]